[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute nach langer zeit
endlich mal die pizza machen die ich
euch versprochen hatte
und zwar mache ich immer ganz gerne
pizza wenn wir zu hause zum beispiel
auch mal reste verwerten wollen wie
gemüse oder wurst oder käse
denn da kann ich einfach alles auf die
pizza mit drauf schmeißen und es
schmeckt immer gut vor allem ist pizza
bei uns so ein gericht ich finde es
dauert nicht lange es ist nicht viel
aufwand und man hat trotzdem was richtig
leckeres als ich weiß von meiner mama
der thema pizza gemacht wenn ganz viele
leute da waren sie hat immer gesagt das
muss sich lohnen wenn ich nicht mal
hinstellen aber ich mache auch mal ganz
gerne selber pizza auch einfach nur für
murat amira und mich weil es einfach
wirklich wenig aufwand ist und ich finde
es lohnt sich da auch gar nicht dass man
da auch mal zum tiefkühl produkt greift
denn bei so fertigpizzen hat man auf das
problem die haben erst mal viel zu viel
kalorien zweites mal haben sie viel zu
wenig drauf und man nimmt einfach nicht
so ganz gesunde zutaten zu sich oftmals
wird das mono käse benutzt und einfach
andere zutaten die einfach sehr günstig
dann erworben werden und einfach drauf
kommen aber den vergleich würde ich euch
einfach am ende des videos noch mal
zeigen und zeigt euch jetzt mal meinen
hefeteig den ich ganz gerne mache für
pizza da ist zu vereinfacht und hier
stehen wir zu treffen ich habe jetzt
hier 900 gramm mehl 500 gramm wasser ich
brauche zwei bis drei teelöffel salz
enthalten würfel hefe oder zwei päckchen
trockenhefe zwei esslöffel zucker und
etwas olivenöl und das geht jetzt auch
ganz schnell ich erlös jetzt mal die
hefe im wasser auf
[Musik]
da gebe ich auch direkt den zucker mit
dazu zucker kommt bei mir im hefeteig
immer mit rein weil ein drittel je
fitter nahrung hat und besser aufgehen
kann
[Musik]
und ich kenne den teig in der
küchenmaschine aber können sie natürlich
auch mit der hand kneten
ich gebe ich die hefe wasser zucker
mischung hinein lebt auch das weizenmehl
mit rein direkt alles denn es ist jetzt
ganz genau gemessen also die die zutaten
stimmen da immer auch salz ich nehme
jetzt zwei gehäufte teelöffel und das
lasse ich jetzt gar nicht kurz verkneten
gebt dann noch sechs esslöffel olivenöl
mit rein und der teig sollte dann auch
mindestens zehn minuten lang geknetet
werden das auch richtig gut wird
[Musik]
und wählen hefeteig richtig lecker
machen wollte habe ich noch ein
geheimtipp für euch gibt einfach noch
ein bisschen frisch gemahlenem pfeffer
betreiben
nach zehn minuten sieht jetzt so aus da
hat sich schön zu einer kugel zusammen
geformt und löst sich hier neben vom
schüssel rand und jetzt teile ich den
teig bereits in vier portionen auf mich
macht nämlich vier prozent raus für
runde
[Musik]
und jetzt vor mich jedes teilstück zu
einer kugel
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt jede teig kugel in eine
separate schüssel rhein mit etwas
olivenöl wird sie dann bedeckt und so
lasse ich die teige dann aufgehen bis
sie sich selber verdoppelt haben dauert
ungefähr eine halbe stunde können so
schön ausruhen genau deckel zu und wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr so was auch schon
am tag vorher machen wenn ihr wisst ich
möchte am nächsten tag besser machen
aber dann dass diese nicht bei
zimmertemperatur stehen sondern einfach
im kühlschrank
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen und ich
zeige euch noch schnell wie ich eine
soße mache und zwar ist das ist meine
schneller pizza soße die nehme ich immer
ganz gern bin ich einen würzigen belag
habt also wenn ich jetzt so was wie
wurst und thunfisch und so weiter drauf
hat nämlich gerne die schnelle soße
ansonsten wenn ich nur eine vegetarische
pizza nach habe ich eine andere soße sie
zeigt sich aber mal in einem anderen
video
ihr braucht dafür eine dose tomaten die
sind jetzt schon fein gestückelte sind
400 gramm eine halbe tomatenmark also
etwa 100 gramm dann noch ein paar
gewürze wie salz pfeffer thymian oregano
und basilikum etwas chili ich brauche
etwas zucker und dann noch die
käsesorten ich nämlich mozzarella und
gouda und jetzt eben noch ein belag nach
wahl ich habe ein bisschen zwiebel
thunfisch ein paar oliven rote paprika
und produkt ich mache zwei verschiedene
pizzen und tun ist dies für die samira
die ist gern tun später zuerst gebe ich
jetzt die tomaten in eine große schüssel
und da können wir gleich die dose mit so
ein bisschen wasser ausspülen
denn es kommt ja gleich tomaten man hört
rein und dann wird das ganze sowieso
wieder fest dann thomas mack
du darfst ja
[Musik]
dann kommt auch hier direkt schon die
frische knoblauchzehe mit rein
die wird rein geräten sorgt natürlich
für den leckeren geschmack
[Musik]
dann etwas pfeffer
eine prise zucker die hebt den tomaten
geschmack und nimmt die säure ein
bisschen weg und gibt es jeweils einen
esslöffel basilikum und oregano einen
teelöffel salz aber da auch bisschen
sparsamer sein falls der belag zu würzig
ist und ich gebe noch eine ganz kleine
tricks der chili mit rein
samira ist damit deswegen nicht so viel
jetzt gut umrühren in japan
[Musik]
und während samira jetzt hier noch die
zwei minuten tomatensoße unberührt kann
ich schon mal in afrika und zwiebeln
klein schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt kann man den teig ausrollen und
ich mache das jetzt ohne ausrollt starb
ihr könnt natürlich auch ein ausbaustopp
nehmen aber ich finde so wie ich das
jetzt mache gibt's einfach in schöneren
luftigeren teig und es gibt eben auch
eine schöne kruste am rand und ich habe
erzählt die arbeitsfläche bestäubt mit
mir hat den hefeteig drauf jetzt
bestäubte ihn nochmal mit mehl und dann
wird er erst noch flach gedrückt und um
jetzt einen schönen rand zu formen formt
jetzt legte die eine hand hierhin um die
anderen dass hier nun drückt ihr hier
von der mitte aus den rand
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich doch immer genug mehl
darunter haben den jetzt denen wir ihn
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich das auf die richtige
größe ausgewählt und nehme jetzt hier
ein backblech und zwar dass hier ganz
viele löcher das sorgt dafür dass die
pizza richtig schön knusprig packt und
darin backe ich echt am liebsten und
dieses recht bestreicht ich jetzt mit
etwas olivenöl nämlich einfach so einen
halben teelöffel in die hand und dann
kommt es hier so drauf
[Musik]
dann legen wir den pizzateig rein
so habt ihr halt echt immer diesen
wunderschönen rand vor allem läuft
nichts aus der pc heraus als ihr könnt
so auch aufgezeigt steinen zum beispiel
backen ohne das was ausläuft aber wie
gesagt finde ich dass das ergebnis aus
diesen pizza formen wirklich schon sehr
knusprig
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die pizza auch direkt
belegen zuerst mit tomatensoße
[Musik]
als nächstes gebe ich eine geschichte
mozzarella drauf den gebe ich immer ganz
gerne unten rein wenn er dann so schön
verläuft
[Musik]
da mache ich jetzt zuerst mora zur pizza
da gebe ich die paprika stück hört drauf
dank die rede
und dieser vors
[Musik]
und dann etwas gouda
auf samir aus pizza kommt jetzt
thunfisch und auf die hälfte mache ich
auch noch ein bisschen zwiebeln zu
mehren keine deswegen dass ich sogar ihr
weg und denkst dann auch ein clown ab
[Musik]
und jetzt wird die pizza im vorgeheizten
backofen bei ober und unterhitze 230
grad für ungefähr 20 minuten gebacken
und ich stelle jetzt auf die mit untere
einschub leisten jetzt auch schön guess
[Musik]
die beiden pizzen sind jetzt aus dem
ofen raus und ich habe es jetzt ganz
kurz abkühlen lassen
jetzt setze ich das hier mal um denn auf
den blechen würde ich nicht schneiden
die gehen dann kaputt und jetzt
schneiden wird die einmal durch
[Musik]
hört man auch richtig dieses schöne
kruste
[Musik]
und so sieht jetzt die suppe pizza aus
von oben stehe ich auf einmal um damit
ihr den knusprigen boden sehen könnt und
das ist was 100 und die setzt jetzt kurz
um den nächsten moment auch noch zu heiß
und ich zeige euch jetzt gleich noch den
vergleich zwischen dieser selbst
gemachte pizza und der fertigpizza de
ist jetzt allerdings noch im ofen und
ihr könnt solche pizzen auch auf vorrat
herstellen und zwar müsste sie dann
einfach zehn minuten lang vor backen
dann nämlich aus dem backofen raus lasst
sie abkühlen und dann können wir sehen
frischhaltefolie einwickeln und einfach
einfrieren und wenn ihr sie dann einfach
mal auf backen wollte weil ihr grab von
von der arbeit nach hause gekommen seid
oder von der schule können wir einfach
rausholen direkt tiefgefroren in den
backofen stecken bei 240 grad oder 220
und können sie dann einfach so in 15 10
bis 15 minuten fertig backen habt dann
nämlich eure eigene tiefkühlpizza immer
auf vorrat so habe ich das auch schon
gemacht als ich das letzte mal schwanger
war und einfach wusste wenn ich im
krankenhaus gehen kann sich der murat
einfach mal was wir machen hatte hier
habe ich jetzt die fertig gebackenen
tiefkühlpizza das ist jetzt einfach
irgendeine als ich mich auch keine
marken erwähnen und diese natürlich
jetzt bei mir gekauft eventuell sogar
günstiger als eine selbstgemachte also
ich finde vom kreislichen her kann man
jetzt nicht sagen ich mache selber und
dann komm ich billiger weg denn es kommt
ja auch drauf an was ihr auf eurem pc
drauf macht wenn ich jetzt ne pizza
margherita man nur mit tomaten und käse
ist dir wahrscheinlich günstiger als
eine fertige aber so fertigpizzen gibt
es ja auch schon teilweise auf ein umbau
oder ab 1 euro 50
da komme ich mit meinen frischen zutaten
natürlich preislich nicht hin aber ich
finde der preis ist bei selbstgemachten
gerichten auch nicht wichtig sondern
eher der geschmack und der
gesundheitliche faktor ich weiß zum
beispiel dass die pizza die ich jetzt
gemacht hat mir sehr gut schmeckt ich
habe meine gewürze mit drin ich habe den
belag drauf dem ich gerne möchte und ich
habe natürlich auch so viel belag drauf
ich möchte also dass jeweils ein
hähnchen pizza und auf der packung steht
da sind jetzt irgendwie 8% hähnchen mit
drauf und ich glaube man kann
gegenstücke eigentlich an einer hand
abzählen wie viel da drauf sind und vor
allem weiß ich dass die zutaten die ich
benutze eben auch frisch sind und was
die gesundheit betrifft weiß ich dass
bei mir ein echter käse zum beispiel
auch drauf ist weil so fertig witten ist
offen industrie käse mit drauf natürlich
nicht bei allen aber bei vielen also man
kann es jetzt nicht pauschalisieren und
wenig sondern fertige pizza gegessen
habe war ich nach einer großen pizza
eigentlich nie satt also ich hätte
glaube ich zwei oder sogar drei essen
können um satt zu werden und beim einer
selbstgemachten ist das land wirklich so
ich es vielleicht eine halbe pizza also
wenns hoch kommt vielleicht mal fünf
stücke aber das war's dann auch dann
habe ich auch schon wieder zu viel
gegessen und ich finde auch es lohnt
sich nicht
eine tiefkühlpizza zu kaufen denn wenn
ich die pizza so vorbereitet und bei mir
auch im tiefkühlfach einfriere habe ich
den zeitlichen faktor eben auch weg da
stelle ich mich einmal in die küche kann
es kurz vorbereiten und kann dann immer
mal nach bedarf die pizza auftauen
ich hoffe ich konnte euch jetzt mit
diesem rezept anregung geben für eure
selbst gemachte pizza wenn er gerne
wünscht kann ich auch noch weitere
variationen machen also gerne könnt ihr
in die kommentare schreiben was für eine
pizza variante ihr gern sehen würdet
dann mach ich dir nämlich auch und ich
freue mich schon auf euer feedback bis
zum nächsten mal
und das rezept gibt auf facebook.de fast
vergessen
[Musik]
marantz mccartney